Hello, everyone.
I'm Brindha Muniappan.
I'm the Director of
Programs here at the museum
and I'm happy to welcome you
to the museum this evening.
I'm also quite pleased to have
Eran Egozy and Jason Levine
here.
I'm sure you're
all eager as well
for a wonderful conversation
and performance this evening.
Eran has probably been
thinking about bringing Jason
to MIT for a long time,
but it was about a year ago
when he and I talked about how
we might bring Jason in front
of the public to have a
conversation about what he does
and why and how.
And, from that conversation
developed tonight's program,
as well as a coding
workshop that Jason
is going to lead on
Thursday here at the museum.
I think there are a couple of
spots left for that workshop
so, if you're interested
in joining us,
please look online at the same
place where you got your ticket
for this program tonight.
So, without further
ado, I'd like
to introduce Eran
Egozy, who is Professor
of the Practice of
Music Technology at MIT,
and you might know him better
as co-founder of Harmonics.
Thanks, Brindha.
Hey, everyone.
Thanks for coming.
I'm really excited,
today, to be introducing
Jason to come talk to you
all and perform for you all.
And then after
that, he and I will
have a little
discussion here and try
to get you guys
involved as well.
It's really awesome to
see students of my class.
Raise your hand, students.
Hey, awesome.
Jason is actually here
for the whole week.
And it's part of a residence
that we're having so, he's
giving this talk tonight
plus the workshop on Thursday
that Brindha talked about.
Bu he's also going to
be lecturing in my class
tomorrow for my class,
Interactive Music Systems,
and will be talking to students
about their final projects
and giving them some
advice about that.
So we're really looking
forward to him working with us
in that capacity.
I met Jason, God we
were talking about this,
I think it was 2011.
It was when I was still
working at Harmonics
and the Kinect
had just come out.
And there was a conference
down at Carnegie Mellon
called The Art and
Code Conference,
and they were particularly
looking at ways
to use code to make cool
art using the Kinect.
So I went down there,
as well as someone
I see here from
Harmonics, Mike Mandel.
And Jason was doing
this crazy performance
where he was on stage
with the screen behind him
and the Kinect was
doing a 3D capture
of his position and his body.
And that was being
rendered onto the screen,
but using waveforms.
And it also turns out he's one
of the world's top beatboxing
artists, so he was beatboxing
and doing this kind of hard
to describe show.
And since then, he's just
done more and more interesting
things and he'll talk
about all of those today.
So, I won't bore you
with more introductions
other to say that,
again, I'm really
excited to have Jason here.
Jason, come on up.
Hello, Hello.
So, my name is
Jason, as you know,
and I'm a computational
artist and musician.
And I'm based in New York,
but I grew up in Montreal,
so I really appreciate
the summer weather you
guys are having right now.
So I've been interested in
music and computers for as long
as I can remember and my parents
took notice of my interest
in computers.
And so they went
to a garage sale
and picked up a used computer.
So this was my first computer.
It was the IBM PC junior, had
128 kilobytes of RAM and 4.7
megahertz CPU and no hard drive.
So, if you have no hard
drive or, any drive
at all, what happens when
you start up a computer?
Well, I would just
get this screen.
I didn't know what
to do with it.
But, lucky for me, it
came with a manual.
So I taught myself
Basic by writing
these choose your own adventure
style text adventures.
So something like, you
see a door, open door.
You enter a room with a
lamp in it, turn on lamp.
You see a dresser with
a drawer, open drawer.
There's a box in the
drawer, and on and on.
So, I would spend all day trying
to build these text adventures
but then every night, my
father would come down
and because, in
these times there
was no sleep mode or
really even screen savers,
the computer had
to be turned off.
And since I had no hard
drive, everything was erased.
So I had this zen-like
practice of trying
to take the text adventure
to the next level each day
until all my work was erased.
And my father was talking with
some friends of my plight,
and so, one of his friends gave
him a 5 and 1/4 disk entitled
DOS 1.1, so I didn't
get the manual
but, I was allowed to
use it once in a while.
So I still didn't
have a hard drive,
but I just basically left
this drive in my computer
all the time.
And there was no
games or much to do,
so I just learned how
to do batch files.
And my one achievement was, I
edited the binary of the system
kernel by hand and I replaced
all instances of exe with fun,
and I swear to God it worked.
Executable files would not run
until you renamed them .fun.
I'm sure you can't
do that anymore,
but, you know, I
had a lot of time.
So, I was clearly looking
for fun in computers
and I found it at
elementary school
where they taught Logo Writer.
So, for those of
you not familiar,
Logo Writer was a programming
language aimed for educators.
And you had this
little turtle and you
could draw a line by saying,
go forward 10 pixels,
turn right 90 degrees, and make
all sorts of abstract geometry.
But, it was advanced
enough you could also make
some animations or even a game.
So it turned out I really
liked it and I don't
remember most of this because
obviously it was 1992.
But, the moment
that I do remember,
was when the three of
us were put in a room
and we were given five problems.
And we had to pick
which three we
were going to solve in this
limited amount of time,
and then we went
to solving them.
And I think it was
my first experience
of the sort of liveness that
can happen in programming.
So around the same time
or maybe a bit earlier,
another friend of my parents
invited me to perform with
the [? Musique ?] de
[? Moliére ?] Chamber Orchestra
doing a Mozart's
music for children.
And I had the cuckoo, which
is the one-holed flute.
And I had one job and that
was to remember the time when
the orchestra stops
and then I go,
toot toot, toot toot, toot
toot toot toot toot toot.
But, the story was,
they never knew
when I was going to come
in, and every time I
invented some new rhythm.
And they had to be on their toes
to know when was the right time
to jump back in.
So, basically by
age 11, I already
had a taste for liveness
in coding, hacking system
critical files without
making a backup
and wild and unruly
musical improvisations.
And now 25 years
later, I'm taller.
So, I did learn spreadsheets,
databases, touch typing and C
in high school, but
really most of my energy
was focused on this
new high energy,
I see you guys are
all like, who are
those bands, this kind
of high energy rock music
that was coming out.
And I liked it so much that
when I finished high school,
I started a band
with some friends
and ended up dropping
out of science
and going to music school.
I was never much
of a bass player,
but one thing that
I really loved
was all the pedals, the delays,
the distortions, the reverbs,
the flanges, the phasors.
These little boxes with
knobs that you could just
control and shape the sound.
But, unlike my guitarist
friends at the time who
were collecting the
little Boss pedals,
I went on a little-known
site called, eBay,
and got a programmable
multi-effects pedal.
So, the signal chain
was fixed, but you
could change which effects
were on and the parameters.
It was very awkward
to program, you
see you have these
little buttons
to move around and change stuff.
But my best friend,
Diego, realized
that you could push the
delay to 3 and 1/2 seconds
and you could set it so when
you pushed the foot pedal up,
it set the feedback
of the delay loop
to 100% making it
into a loop pedal.
Now, I know today, live
looping is practically
a musical genre of
its own and there is
plenty of dedicated hardware.
But, back in 2000-2001,
there was nothing.
Maybe just one rack mount
unit from TC Helicon
that cost a couple grand.
So, Diego got one
of these pedals,
and we started a group
called Tabula Rasa.
And I played all sorts of
percussion, guitar, beatboxing
and throat singing.
And he played bass,
flute and singing,
but the truth was, we were
really playing the pedals.
So we had these
choreographies where
we would change effects
at the same time
to create these song structures
and polyrhythmic effects.
But I felt like I needed even
more programmatic control.
So we got this 26-channel
mixer and connected everything
we possibly could
to it and set it up
so you could send
any signal anywhere.
And even send the
pedals to each other
and create these wild
feedback effects.
So we did that for
a couple of years
but ultimately, it was too
complicated and unwieldy
to perform with live.
And, so, we created a more
stripped down live band.
After music school, I went
to do computer science.
But, again, I spent
more time beatboxing
than actually going to school.
I beatboxed in bars and clubs
and weird circus festivals
in the forest.
And then I would put
on a shirt and beatbox
in a wholesome a capella group.
But I just couldn't get
down with the way computer
science was taught.
There wasn't much
coding, to be honest.
And it was just very dry,
static and theoretical.
Until halfway
through my degree I
found out that I could do a
minor in music technology.
And this is where I learned
about physical computing
and, especially, Max MSP.
So this was just an
absolute game changer.
It solved, wait, raise of hands
if you've heard of Max MSP,
yeah, that's what I thought.
This is just a
game changer coming
from the kind of hardware
system with this mess of cables
because now, I could set up my
signal chain however I wanted,
I could have as many
delays as I want,
loops as long as I wanted.
But even more than that,
there was this notion
of interactivity that you
could take a sensor to control
parameters or, my
favorite was using
the signal of a performer
to actually affect
their own signal.
An example of that.
This is a performance.
So, whenever the singer holds
a note for three seconds,
it captures the eight loudest
harmonics in her voice
and tunes some
resonant filters, which
I'm then beatboxing through.
And then we're improvising.
[BEATBOXING]
But as much as I love
music technology,
I felt so burnt out from
the computer science degree.
And in the end, I
decided, you know
what, I think I'm going to
follow the path of performance.
And I literally ran away
and joined the circus.
So, I played, most
notably, I was
the beatboxer emcee in a Kung
Fu themed street circus group.
But, I also battled
flamenco dancers,
accompanied DJs, and this
picture in the corner
here, that's not
even a circus group.
Those are my
roommates at the time.
And so, I literally thought
this would be my life.
I'd travel the world just
beatboxing and repeating
silly comedy lines.
But then one by one all
my circus collaborators
started studying
contemporary dance.
And I remember, when my
closest collaborator [? Manu ?]
[INAUDIBLE] asked me to vocally
accompany and be the soundtrack
for his first choreography.
And we were in this
acoustically dry room
and I was trying to do my
explosive sound effects,
but he was doing all these
subtle and bizarre movements
and it just didn't work.
So I knew exactly
what I had to do.
I dug up some old Max patches
and I created a system
with this very long
delay that was slowly
increasing in
feedback, so that it
began with very
one-to-one sound effects,
but slowly became a
layered soundscape.
[WHOOSHING]
[SOUNDSCAPE PLAYING]
So, I continued to work
with the circus groups
but also start
incorporating more
of these interactive
audio systems
into the work with performers.
But what I started to feel was
that these complex and subtle
interactions and sounds
needed to be visualized.
I did a little bit of work
visualizing with Max MSP.
But then, someone told
me about something called
openFrameworks.
I see a smile over here.
So openFrameworks, when I first
heard of openFrameworks I said,
Oh man, I haven't done C++
in like five years since I
finished my degree, I don't
know if I remember it anymore.
But it only took
me one time to know
that this would be
my tool of choice
because, unlike the
black boxes of Max MSP,
I could have direct manipulation
of data at the lowest levels.
And just have high performance
graphics and an easy interface
to work with all sorts of
media from video, to images,
to graphics, to sound.
And so I started making visuals
with openFrameworks but then
again I felt like
I wish there was
a way that the
visuals could be aware
of the physical performers.
So I started doing some
research into IR sensors
and I dreamt up this
whole system that
was going to cost
me one or two grand
and it would have been
super complicated to set up,
and hard to use.
And, you've probably
guessed the punch line,
because around then, Microsoft
released the Xbox for Kinect.
Sorry, Kinect for Xbox.
And as soon as it was released,
Adafruit put a bounty on it
for a couple of grand, whoever
could hack the drivers.
So, within one month,
there was full support
for the Kinect in
openFrameworks.
So I set to creating interactive
video pieces with dancers.
So this is a piece
with video feedback
and the angle and
scale of the projection
is controlled by
where the dancer is.
This is tracking the vectors
of the movement of the dancer.
And then in this one, it's
a particle system reacting
to the dancer's movements.
But what you can't see
or, maybe can't see,
is that these are all letters.
And they're the
letters of a poem.
And the piece begins with
him reciting the poem.
And as he starts to
move away, the letters
all start to follow
him like alphabet soup.
And the way we created
this piece was,
I had a sort of basic
particle system,
and then he would dance with it
and then give me suggestions.
Can it start from this and
these letters leave first.
Maybe it moves along
this type of curve.
And so, every time you
give me a suggestion,
I would quit the system and
then I'd start typing like mad
and try and turn the idea into
reality, start up the app again
and then we'd
iterate in that way.
And so, I didn't know about
live coding at the time,
but that's what I
was trying to do.
The only problem was that
I had to quit the app
and then the dancer couldn't
interact with the system
while I was making
changes to it.
So, I refined the technique.
And this is with a dance company
in New York called Eric Taylor
Dance.
And, this led to me working with
the legendary Miss Lauryn Hill.
I got to do audio
reactive visuals for her.
And it was great
because the entire band,
I got an audio signal from
every member of the band
and then I could
choose which visuals
and what part of
the projection were
reacting to her voice or
the drums or guitar solo.
Here's the--
LAURYN HILL: (SINGING) I
treat this like my thesis.
Well-written topic
broken down into pieces.
I introduce then produce.
Words so profuse.
It's abuse how I juice up
this beat like I'm deuce.
Two people both equal Like
I'm Gemini rather simeon.
If I Jimmy on this
lock I could pop it.
You can't stop it.
Drop it.
Your whole crew's microscopic.
Like particles while I make
international articles.
And on the cover.
Don't discuss the
baby mother business.
I been in this third LP you
can't tell me, I witness.
First handed.
I'm candid.
You can't stand it.
Respect demanded.
And get flown around the planet.
Rock hard like granite or steel.
People feel Miss Hill
from Brooklyn to Israel.
And this is real.
So I keep makin' the
street's ballads.
While you lookin' for
dressin' to go with--
You could get the money.
You could get the power--
So just one geeky aside, if
there's any signal enthusiasts
out there.
Lauryn Hill's voice is a
really incredible signal.
It's just different.
She's legendary.
But let's go back in time.
The first piece I
actually created
when I first got the
Kinect and openFrameworks
working together,
was a solo piece
that was a synthesis of my work
in physical theater, dance,
beatboxing and
interactive video.
And that was called [INAUDIBLE].
And this is the piece
that Eran was mentioning.
[SOUND EFFECTS]
And back in the day when I'd
send this video to people,
it was impossible to
convince them that there
was no post-processing.
[BEATBOXING]
So I got to take the
performance on the tour.
And the first stop
was Art && Code 3D,
which was the Kinect Hacking
Conference put on by Golan
Levin in the STUDIO for Creative
Inquiry at Carnegie Mellon.
And something amazing happened
during my performance there.
And, well, not amazing but,
that is that the code crashed.
And it crashed
right in the middle.
So if it had crashed
at the beginning,
I would have asked the
audience, can I start again.
And if it had
crashed near the end,
I would have just
pretended that that's
where it was supposed to end.
But it crashed
right in the middle
and it actually crashed to the
point where the visuals go dark
and it's just ambient
right before the build up
to the final climax.
So I just, jumped off
stage, I forced quit the app
and I just started debugging
in front of the whole audience.
So I commented out
some code here,
I changed some numbers there.
It was a mad dash.
I wasn't sure if it
was going to work.
I hit compile and we all watched
as the rainbow beach ball went,
and it compiled.
And I jumped up on stage,
now full of adrenaline,
and I finished the show.
And the amazing part
was, multiple times
throughout the weekend
of that conference,
people came up to me
and they were like,
hey man, your show
is pretty cool,
but that part where it crashed
and then you debugged it
and then it worked,
that made my weekend.
I was like, really?
And I was so curious
but, it sort of
planted the seed that,
Oh, can programming
be a performance practice?
Anyway, when I
first got off stage,
this unassuming
guy came up to me
and he said, hey, you probably
wouldn't be interested
but, I have a
video game company,
maybe we can work together.
He gave me a card and it said,
Eran Egozy, CTO of Harmonics.
So the next stop on
the tour was Harmonics,
where I got to play
for the entire company
during their lunch
hour, which was a really
interesting experience.
Then, I went to Columbia to
play the International Image
Festival, to India
to the Carnival
for e-Creativity, and
then finally to Norway
for the Piksel
Festival, which is
a really interesting
open-source software art
conference festival.
And at Piksel, there was all
these amazing and very strange
performances, all with Linux.
And one of them was this guy
writing code in an Emacs buffer
and creating these groovy beats.
And after the show
I said, hey man what
was that, that was incredible.
And he said, Oh it's just
a [? haska ?] library
I wrote, and then walked away.
I guess he was in a rush because
I didn't even catch his name.
But that was Alex McClain, who
is a pioneer in the live coding
movement and the creator
of Title Cycles, which
is used a lot at what are called
algoraves, where people dance
to algorithmically
created music.
After the tour I
went to Harmonics
to work on this incredible
project called Fantasia:
Music Evolved, which was to
take the classic 1940s Disney
movie, Fantasia, and make
it an interactive game where
you could manipulate music.
And so, they hired me to come
in and I couldn't believe it.
They said, we want you to
just make cool things where
you manipulate music
using the Kinect
and there's cool visuals.
Are you serious?
OK.
So, here's a little
example of the game.
Now, if you haven't tried
the game, you should try it.
It's extremely expensive.
I can't possibly show--
[MUSIC- LORDE, "ROYALS"]
(SINGING) [INAUDIBLE]
So this was one of the
things that I contributed
to the game, where the user can
manipulate this sort of womp
bass in a sound or some other--
as it were sort of a late--
I know it was pretty abstract.
And one memory I
have at Harmonics,
so I did about three
contracts with Harmonics.
And at the end of
one of them I don't
know if it was the
first or the second,
but I sort of got
this vibe like I
needed to make another
good idea if I was
going to get another contract.
And so, I just started
hustling and I ended up
making five different
interactive prototypes
in five days.
I remember on the Friday Eran
and the other execs came in
and they kind of looked
at my stuff they said,
Oh that's cool, you
know, that doesn't work,
maybe this could work with that.
And then after they left,
Eran said, good work, man, I
like this one
prototype a day thing.
And I went, Oh no, oh no.
I set this precedent.
But then, I thought
about it, and I
was like no, this is
the most amazing thing
that I love about this medium.
That you can have an idea for an
interactive audio-visual system
and create it in a
day and then people
can interact with it by
moving their hands in the air.
And that is the
magic that I've been
after throughout my career.
So, I got to work creating
interactive gestural control
instruments again.
This, recently, with a
company called the WaveVR.
It's a social VR world where
people go to concerts together.
So this is from the point of
view of the person who's in VR
and they're remixing,
I should say,
this is LA producer, first-ever
album released in VR.
So the team took her
album art and turned it
into an entire world that
people could explore.
This is remixing drum
samples from the album.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And now in this one
each globe represents
one of the stems,
one of the tracks,
so the user's holding the drums.
And then these are
different filters
that they can put them into.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
This is the keys track.
[INAUDIBLE] So VR, in a way,
is a successor to the Kinect
in that it's this
incredibly precise way
to do gestural control.
Of course, you've got to
hold things in your hand
and wear goggles on your face.
But, so, this is actually about
five years after Harmonics.
But right after Harmonics, I
was accepted into the School
for Poetic Computation, which
is a project of Taeyoon Choi
and Zach Lieberman
and many others.
And so this was the
first class in 2013.
It was a really
incredible program.
It was just this deprogramming
kind of education
where you jumped
from topic to topic.
Sometimes the students
talk the teachers,
the class content changed
within one lesson.
And the first
assignment Zach ever
gave was really amazing because
he said, find a programming
language you've never heard
of or at least, never used,
and just do something
with it, anything.
And so I kind of went
down this rabbit hole
of trying all these
new languages.
And that's where I found
out about live coding.
Now I had heard
some live coding,
this sort of blips and noise
and complex rhythmic stuff.
But this was totally different.
This is some code from a
language called Impromptu
created by Andrew Sorenson.
And, this is called
A Study in Keith.
And, it's inspired by the
Jazz pianist, Keith Jarrett.
And the first 2 minutes
are silent while he sets up
the base algorithms for
the structure of the piece.
And I love this because it's
kind of got like a John Cage
feel, but it's functional.
But I'll skip ahead here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So this is so
different from what
you think of when you
think of algorithmic music.
And if you look right over
here, what he's typing,
this is a super
minimal Markov chain.
So Markov chain is usually
seen as a black box
and you feed it tons
of data and then you
use it to predict
the next turn based
on the last couple of terms.
But, here, he's
writing it from scratch
and then adding in to
create chord progressions.
And, so, I love this idea of
sort of immediate programming
and it's almost artisanal in the
data and the code is together.
[PIANO PLAYING]
So this really was
the moment for me
when I realized that coding
would be my performance
practice, because before
when I was bringing code
and performance together, really
I would spend a couple of weeks
head down creating
an interactive system
and then I'd spend a
couple of weeks practicing
with the system.
So it was still
separated in time.
And there's a great paper
called Programming in Time
by Andrew Sorensen
and Henry Gardner,
talking about how,
traditionally, programming
has been split into a
problem to be solved,
its implementation
and then a product
to be used in the future.
And this software
development ideology
is just how everyone
thinks about programming.
But, it's nothing to
do with the hardware.
It doesn't have to be this way.
And, so, he talked about
this more ephemeral kind
of programming where
it's direct agency.
And you have ideas, you
turn them into code,
and in the moment, you start
changing the sound waves,
or, the photons in the room.
And so, I started to look
for like-minded souls.
And it turns out
it's a very spread
out international community.
There's a little hub in England,
in Mexico City, in Australia.
But not too many
people in New York.
So, we started a group
with just four of us.
So there's Kate Sicchio,
who live codes dancers.
So this is sort of following
in the Merce Cunningham
games of chance sort of idea,
where she's algorithmically
creating choreographies that
the dancers are reacting to
in real time.
And then there's
Ramsey Nasser, who's
created his own system for
live coding video games.
So, while someone's
playing the game,
he can change the
mechanics of the game.
And then there's Tom
Murphy and myself,
who were traditional live
coders, live coding dance
music and such.
And so, we're now about 10 core
members over 80 total members
and we've put on about 15
algoraves and two live coding
festivals, and we'd
love to do one here.
So I want to talk
about how different
it is as a as a
musician to live code
than just when you're
a human musician.
And so as a musician, you're
always sort of in the moment.
You've got this muscle memory,
your body is the instrument,
and you have all these
internalized ideas
of musical structures
and culture.
And so you're living
in the moment,
you have a little bit of the
past and a little bit of what
could happen in the future.
And you can be very
fast and emotional.
But when you're live
coding, the process
is completely different.
You're in your computer,
you hear the music,
you think of how you
want to change it
and then you imagine how to
turn that into an algorithm.
And then how to
type that in code
fast enough so that when
you evaluate the change,
it makes musical sense.
And if you listen to a
lot of live coding music
and you have a
musical background,
you'll notice that
most of it doesn't
follow the norms of
musical structure at all,
and that's why.
But I really wanted to
create something musical.
And so, I formed a duo with
singer-songwriter Mae Cheung.
And she has a background in jazz
and she's a strong improviser.
And what I realized was, when
I'm thinking about what to do,
while I'm thinking how to
turn into an algorithm,
while I'm typing, I
still hear her voice
in the corner of my ear.
And her phrasing
guides me to know
when to make a change to the
music, went to go half time,
when to change the key.
And so here's an example of
some of the music we make.
People are confused.
And we just have
these moments where
we change at the same time.
Yeah and we've been lucky to
play all over New York, LA,
touring in Mexico and Hong Kong.
And just being greeted with
appreciation for this strange,
sort of improvisational
electronic music that we do.
People wear sunglasses to shows.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So I want to take
the next little bit
to explain my
process and how I've
come to the audio visual system
that I'm going to be presenting
you this evening.
So just to give you an
idea of the basic way
you make rhythms
and live coding is
it's a succession of
repeated conditionals.
So you might say, every
fourth beat, play a kick drum.
[BEATBOXING] And then on the
third beat of every four beats,
do a snare drum.
[BEATBOXING] Play two
high hats every beat.
[BEATBOXING] So, that's kind
of very direct and one-to-one.
But I wanted to find a
way to go one level higher
and get more emergent rhythms.
So what I started doing
was putting low frequency
oscillators, sine
waves and such,
and sampling them to choose
from a list of drums.
So here's a simple example
with just three drums.
You'll see as I change
the frequency of the drum,
you get some
interesting rhythms.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So, I started to push
this and I had 10 drums
that I sorted by hand from
lowest to highest pitch, 20,
30.
But I wanted more.
I wanted like, 100
or 1,000 drums.
And I knew I couldn't
have them all in one line.
So I had to find a way
to have more dimensions.
And right around
the time when I was
trying to figure
out this problem,
this image turned
up on the internet,
circulating Reddit
with the tagline,
a computer made
this art by itself.
Spoiler alert, computer
didn't make that art.
It was the DeepMind
group at Google.
And this came out of
some research to try
and figure out how the
state of the art neural
networks for image object
recognition and images worked.
And so, just to simplify
it, basically, playing
these neural networks
backwards makes
them hallucinate and create
these beautiful or grotesque,
depending on your taste, images.
So this was called Deep
Dream or inception.
So one of the effects that
this new aesthetic had
was a lot of artists working
with code or media artists
started getting interesting
in the potential
of machine learning and AI.
And, I was at an event at
Dark Matter in Brooklyn,
and I saw an artist named Kyle
McDonald, who's presenting
some of his recent work.
And he had all these
clusterings of words
clustered by similarity,
or scales, or images.
And they all were clustered
in this interesting way.
And then the last one was
this giant point cloud.
And as he dragged
his mouse through it,
I realized every point was a
sample organized by similarity
and that's it,
that's what I need.
So I said, what's this
called, what do you
call that algorithm?
And he said, t-SNE.
So t-SNE stands for
t-distributed Stochastic
Neighbor Embedding.
The t hyphen actually stands
for t hyphen distributed.
So it's a
revolutionary algorithm
and a revolutionary acronym.
And, basically,
what this does is
it's a dimensionality
reduction algorithm.
But, in simplest terms, it puts
similar things close together
and doesn't care about
things that are different.
So these are images, it's
a low resolution image.
And so, I took some samples
and I ran a t-SNE on it.
So, here, the blue points are
high hats, the red are snare
and the green are kick drums.
So this is the
algorithm in action.
Every little dot
finds its place.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So, it worked.
So, now I had to live code it.
So, I took 3,000 samples
and I put everything.
I put marimbas, and
vibraphones, and trumpets,
as well as all my
percussion samples.
And I started live coding
traversals through it
and it sounded like This.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And I memorized this geography.
I knew where a
marimba island was.
I knew where on the
percussion continent
to find the darbuka
or the djembe.
But, after working on
it for about two years,
I figured out there was
a better way to do it.
And that was, that if I took
out all the tonal samples,
the marimbas, and the
vibraphones and the trumpets,
and just had more dry percussion
sounds, what it was actually
doing was organizing it from
the lowest kick to the highest
pitched high hat.
And, it's just that the t-SNE
tries to conserve space,
so it was crushing it into
some sort of weird curve.
And so what that meant,
you'll see in a second.
Basically, you could
draw a curve through it.
So you draw a curve
through the distribution.
And I tried all sorts of ways
of curve-fitting algorithms,
but it just always is
better if I did it by hand.
And then you could unwrap it.
And then assign it to a grid.
And now, there's two
meaningful dimensions.
So, along this
way, the drums are
getting from low-pitched
to high-pitched.
And then on this
axis, it's variations
within the same
frequency energy.
And so then, I didn't
have to memorize anymore.
I knew numerically
where the drums were.
And so, I got commissioned
again by the WaveVR
to turn the live coding
t-SNE into a VR experience.
And I'll just show you
some early sketches.
So, you're on a giant
laptop and you're watching
the t-SNE being formed.
You see me code a little bit.
But then, what's interesting
is, that the users
get to enter, and this
is a three dimensional
t-SNE of samples, and
make their own rhythms.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So, I started to
think, what the t-SNE
would do to different kinds
of musical structures.
So this is all the diatonic
seventh chords in every key.
And I was very
proud of the t-SNE
because, chords find their
friends, and it makes a circle.
And so, this is sort
of a circle of fifths.
And if you unwrap it, again
you get two dimensions.
One where it's variations
on the same chord.
And then on the x-axis,
whenever you move over one,
one note is different.
If you move over two,
two notes are different.
And you're always moving
towards the next key
in the circle of fifths.
So now I can create
progressions without knowing
what chords I'm playing
just by how far I want
them to change harmonically.
So, this is a t-SNE of
synth presets interpolating
between the nearest
[? seven ?] to the mouse.
[WHOOSHING]
And the reason that
there's so few points
is, because when you make
a t-SNE, you want to have,
ideally, a lot of points.
And, I'm using the
presets to compare,
is that every commercially
available synth that I've
been able to find has
modal parameters where
there's switches, or switching
between waveform or modes.
And you just can't interpolate
or you get all sorts of clips.
So I curated these because they
all have their modal switches
at the same place.
So, if you know a synth
that is fully parametric,
please come talk to
me after the talk.
And this is a t-SNE working
on every possible rhythm
with eight beats.
And, again, the
t-SNE surprised me
with the topology it
found because it basically
made this fractal grid.
So that all I had
to do was rotate it.
And then kind of clean it up.
And then, again it
has the property
where if I move over by one, the
beat is different by one beat.
And if you move over by
two it's different by two.
I couldn't find any
meaning in the axes,
but it is an interesting
way to explore rhythms.
Then, I got a little
distracted from music.
This is a t-SNE grid of
my former collaborator
from circus days, B-boy WD-40.
This is every frame
in a 15 second clip.
And I don't have time
to show you right now,
but I've done some
experiments where
if you move through this
at a fast speed, put, kind
of, triangle waves
through it, you
can get him to do all
sorts of choreographies
that he never did.
That's interesting.
Then, I took this
image of a flower
and did a t-SNE me
of all the pixels.
And the background is
just blue to make it pop.
So this is the t-SNE
unwrapping the pixels.
And it kills me every
time that it tears here.
But, the t-SNE is
optimizing for things
that are nearby being similar.
So, sometimes groups
get broken up.
Then, I think I went
too far, because I
did a t-SNE of the
images in the sequence
of the t-SNE of the pixels
of the image of the flower.
And by this point, people were
just like messaging me like,
you OK man, you sure
are tweeting a lot about
[? t-SNE's. ?]
And, truth be told,
I was literally dreaming
about t-SNE at night.
So, I started to
think, what else can
this, kind of, new revival,
and AI, and machine learning
bring to musical creativity.
So, when DeepDream
first was released,
I was really
fascinated by the way
it could take content and
superimpose new content
in this, sort of, hallucinatory,
eidetic way, that it
knows about the shape of
the tree and it fills it in.
And I talked to some
people working in the field
and I was like, can
we do this for sound.
I'd love to take the
sound of a babbling brook
and turn it into distant
djembes or something.
And they're like,
no, this algorithm
won't work on sound
because this algorithm only
understands spatial
relationships
and it can't make sense of time.
But it only took one more
year until the same group
at DeepMind created WaveNet.
And so, the real breakthrough
of WaveNet is speech synthesis.
It's kind of the best
and most natural speech
synthesis we have yet, and
this just came out in 2016.
But, of course, I wasn't
interested in speech synthesis.
I wanted to hear
some weird noises.
Lucky for me, the lovely
folk at Google Magenta, which
is a group at Google devoted
to finding how AI and machine
learning can benefit artists and
creativity, they felt the same.
So, they trained
WaveNet on 400,000
individual audio samples of
instruments playing one note.
And you can see here
this ridiculous encoding.
This is the original spectrogram
and then, 10 to 15 features,
and with that they can
reproduce the original waveform.
So it's happening
on a waveform basis.
And there's some crunchy
artifacts that turn up
which, of course, I love.
I don't know what's going
on with the flugelhorn.
But what was really cool,
is that you could say,
I want something
that's 20% base,
30% glockenspiel,
and 50% flugelhorn.
And it's not cross-fading
those sounds by amplitude,
it's generating what it
thinks the mix of those
would be sample per sample.
And so, they released a Max for
Live plug-in for Ableton Live.
And basically, you can
pick different grids
and you have four
instruments and you
can interpolate between them.
In the middle of
these instruments
you get to these weird places
where it's kind of not in tune
because the tuning of a
violin for a certain note
is not the same as a tuning
for, say, a saxophone.
So you can get these very
strange harmonics and crunchy
things.
And so, I'm going to perform
that for you tonight.
So I think this is a fairly
good intro to my work.
I want to spend the
next hour going deep
into the philosophical
implications,
no I'm just kidding.
I'm going to do a little set up
where I switch the projectors
and then I'm going
to perform for you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thanks, Jason.
That was amazing.
So, we're going to chat.
Although, I'm still sort
of coming down from that.
Thanks.
I tried to bring
it down at the end.
Yeah, no, it was good.
I don't know if you guys
had the same experience
but, I was sort of wondering,
do I look at the code,
do I look at the
screen, because they
were both very interesting.
So, I wanted to have the
code overlaid on the screen.
But I couldn't find a text
editor that would properly
do transparency the
background without the text,
and I didn't want to
learn Emacs for the show.
Right, right that's
probably a good idea.
You're a Vim guy, OK.
Well, we won't get
into editor wars
right now because
that's a whole--
I'm using Vim key bindings.
Vim key bindings.
So we're good.
OK, so, look--
I think she started
a war already.
Yeah, don't start
the editor war.
But I have to say, I
thought it worked OK
because it was, code on top of
art might be a little too much,
it's pretty busy.
Just out of curiosity,
oh turn your mic up.
So, out of the
audience, who spent
more time looking at the code?
OK, and then who
looked at the screen?
OK.
50-50.
So then that was the
right thing to do.
I think that's right.
[INAUDIBLE] But then you get
like the indigo [INAUDIBLE]
So there's a ton
we can talk about.
I could spend a
while just asking you
about details of the code
and what you were doing.
But I'm going to
resist doing that.
I also do live coding
of a different sort
which is, in my class I actually
code in front of the class.
And that's got its own set
of terrors associated with it
because it's all MIT students.
So as soon as you type one wrong
character, they're just like,
hey you don't need to do that.
I was pretty low
typo rate today.
Then at the end I was like--
I will ask you some broader
questions about that.
I'm sort of wondering
what's going on in your head
as you're essentially
constructing this piece.
And it starts nice and easy.
There's not a lot of
code on the screen.
You get the metronome set up and
you get your first basic beats
going, but then you're
building up more and more.
And so, I'm wondering what's
going on through your head
as that's happening?
And also, does it
ever get overwhelming,
like do you ever forget,
where did I put that code
or is it all fairly
clear in your mind
how it's all architected
and what it's doing?
Well, because I'm improvising,
sometimes I'll get to a point,
like today I got
to a point where
I wanted to stop the drums,
and then immediately take out
the root note of the chords.
And I did it and then
I said, Oh, this time
I put the chords at the top,
and they're not beside this.
So, all those little
chunks of code
are called temporal recursions.
It just schedules
itself to be called
in the future at a certain time.
So each one is sort of
a self-contained unit?
Not everything.
There's some one-off
commands like, I'm
sending messages to
this computer on how
to control the visuals.
But mostly, Yeah, I set
up a temporal recursion,
you give it a name, and then
you tell it to call itself back
in the future.
And then the ways you
can create rhythms
are you put
conditionals in there,
only play on these beats.
Or, the way I get the
really interesting stuff
is, I'm actually changing
how soon to call itself back
in the future.
So it calls itself,
and then it decides,
Oh next time I'm going to call
myself an eighth note or maybe
a triplet.
And that's where you get
the more interesting sort
of things.
So you can get these, sort
of, dynamically forming
polyrhythms.
Yeah, and then the
most interesting thing
which I didn't get
to do, is where
you can have one call a
different function instead
and that function
might call it back
and so they're
feeding off each other
and passing each
other parameters.
But I kept it pretty
self-contained.
I also noticed, you
probably noticed
but, you're using
random here and there,
but sparingly, which I
thought was kind of cool.
You can get quickly carried
away probably with randomness,
but it's nice to see that.
Well, so I actually
don't like randomness.
I try and avoid it.
But the one place
where I really like
it is in the parameters of the
oscillators and, specifically,
the frequencies.
So I'll say, the
frequency of this
is, it takes two beats
for this wave to play,
but one out of three times,
it takes three beats for it
to play.
And that that's where I find
the random really interesting.
And then maybe I'll use it
in the amplitude of the wave,
and just give it two.
So, sometimes it's
playing nearby
and then sometimes
it'll go a bit further.
But I don't I don't
like just random.
It's another style.
Yeah, interesting.
So I don't I don't do
much improvising, myself,
as an instrumentalist.
But I imagine when
you are improvising,
there's a lot going in your but
it's probably not necessarily
just the individual note.
Like, John Coltrane
is not thinking,
C sharp, D, F natural.
He's thinking larger
shapes and forms
as this all was happening.
And, of course, generally
you're conforming
to a particular
tune you're playing
with a certain set
of chord changes.
But I'm wondering, with this
it all seems very detailed.
Where do you think you
are, sort of, on this arc?
Not, not Coltrane.
Not yet, but, in this
arc where initially,
this is a new
instrument, essentially,
and so you start off and
you're just doing scales
and you're practicing
the individual notes
and you're getting
accustomed to your instrument
and learning how it works.
And then over time, you
are able to start thinking
in larger scale structures.
And I wonder if there's an
analog between that learning,
and development and
cultivating of yourself
as a musician in the traditional
way versus the system
that you're working with here.
Yeah, so there is.
But the problem is,
I'm also a coder.
So, I'll practice with a system
and start getting somewhere
and then I'll think, Oh,
maybe if I just change this.
And then I'll totally
change the system.
And I would say almost
100% every show is not
the same system
as the last show.
So you can't--
And wait, sorry,
and when you say
the system you don't mean like
the particular code you're
typing now, you mean the
underlying sort of engine,
so to speak.
Right, so you can see there's
some functions I call,
so that's changing.
And so, extempore, which
is the language I'm using,
is a bilingual language.
So I'm writing a scheme here.
But some of the functions I'm
calling are in what's called,
[? XT ?] [? Lang. ?] And this
is a low-level language like C,
but still written like Lisp.
And so I've built
this whole system for,
you give it an xy point and
the number of nearest neighbors
and it'll find those nearest
neighbors in the grid.
And then based on how
far away they are,
kind of share the
amplitude and the panning.
And all of that is written
in this lower level.
And I'm constantly
changing that too,
so the semantics are changing,
the function is changing.
And I keep saying I want to stop
and then just practice with it,
but it never happens,
so there's that.
But, also to your
point about Coltrane's
not thinking of what
the specific note is.
I don't know if it
was him who said,
they asked him his advice for
young musicians and he said,
learn your scales and then
forget all that bullshit.
And so, like I said there's
the declarative, like,
play this note now,
play this drum now.
And, I'm at least
one step above that
where I'm shaping waves
using amplitude and frequency
modulation to create
these complex waves
and then sampling from
them, rhythmically,
to pick notes from scales.
And that really seems like
this pretty nice ingenuity.
And I think what we saw
here initially is the grid.
That's your unrolled t-SNE grid.
That's the unrolled t-SNE
and then it rolls back up
and then it goes to
the three dimensions.
Right, but in terms
of how you organize
your samples, that's essentially
a thing that gets you--
I'm always giving
numbers to the grid,
regardless of what it's showing.
But in terms of just, you're
saying you don't really
choose a note anymore.
You are thinking
one level higher
now because you
essentially have this sort
of spatial
organization of sound.
And now you're thinking
of traversing through
that as opposed
to saying, I want
this one particular high hat.
Yeah and there's
even more than that
because I can't even say I
want this particular high hat,
because there was one
drum that I really wanted
to play because it
goes like [BEATBOXING]
and is really cool.
And it's at position x 14y zero.
But, every time I play--
That's the best position for it.
Well, it's memorable.
I will always remember that.
Remember it forever.
But, what else I'm doing is,
so I'm creating these chord
progressions by
putting the sine waves
through that grid of chords.
But, when every one
of those drum samples
is tagged with the approximate
pitch, and when I play a chord,
only drums that are tagged
with one of those four pitches
are going to be chosen from
the algorithm that finds
the end nearest neighbors.
So, if I put in [? 14-zero ?]
like I did at the end,
I was like, Oh, come on.
It's got to hit the chord
where it plays that sound,
but it didn't.
So I can't choose
the exact sound.
It's almost like a
limitation of the system
that you've built
yourself in order
to be able to achieve
a higher level--
So when I play with Mae,
with Scorpion Mouse,
sometimes we're
jamming and she's like,
can you change that
third chord, like I
don't like the way the
dominant goes to the three.
And I'm like, can you tell me
when the third chor-- like,
I'm like, no.
So I don't have that, I'm
too high level that when
I work with human musicians,
there's definitely a language
barrier where I'm trying to
figure out, what do they expect
or how could I do that.
But it's also a
really good challenge
that helps me grow is trying
to work with musicians.
As opposed to, say, you, right?
Me or like, so I've been
to a bunch of live coding
conferences and they'll have
on-site live coding ensembles.
It's like, holy shi--
wow.
I don't even think they
know what sound they're
making, because everyone
can make every sound--
Oh so it just all blends
together into this wild--
I mean, everyone has
access to oscillators,
and samples, and
noise and filters
and they're all typing away.
Any questions?
I thought I'd open up to
questions of the audience
and, let's see, there's a
microphone going around.
Oh cool, OK.
So, speak into the mic so we
can get the question recorded.
But, yeah, go ahead.
Here.
What happens when you get
an error on your code?
Does it just not play that part?
Yeah I did miss a parameter.
So, because it's a
dynamic language, when
it goes to call
itself in the future
and the new version
has an error,
it just doesn't play it and I
get an error in the console.
There's another version.
So that's, I'm using the
dynamics scheme language.
You can also do all this
with the low-level language.
And if you make
an error there, it
doesn't replace the function.
If it doesn't compile,
it won't do it.
So in a way that's better.
But then you have to
program with types.
And I just can't,
I just can't do it.
It slows me down.
Yeah.
And with this being
interpreted, it
doesn't know that
there is a bug in it
until it actually
tries to execute it.
Until it executes it
and then it stops.
Yeah.
OK, yes, over here.
Yes, just wait for the mic.
Thank you.
So in an ensemble
situation, some
of the music that
you're performing today
so rhythmically is kind
of the basis for it.
So, do you synchronize
clock with other people
or and I'll ask separately if
you're playing with a drummer,
I don't know if you do that.
But if you're playing with
a live percussionist, what's
your concept on the
rhythmic framework?
I try to avoid playing
with live drummers.
It's happened but,
it's never going
to work because, I
can't groove with them.
If you tell me
exactly, like, you
want the snare a 30 second note
late, I can do that easily.
But, natural drummers
have a groove,
the way they speed
up and slow down
and they move with
the whole band.
And so, basically, it's like
they have to drum to a click,
except it's not a click.
It's my really strange rhythms.
And I just think, frequency-wise
there's too much overlap.
So then for when I work
with other live coders,
yes, synchronize clock.
Synchronized clock
sometimes is a problem
because there's a lot of
really popular live coding
languages like, Tidal and
SuperCollider and ChucK
and, that's what I'm
missing, Sonic Pi.
And these ones often will
work with each other.
But, I'm kind of
like lone wolf here.
Extempore, I mean there's some
other uses around the world
but, mainly, it's the
creator and his collaborators
in Australia.
So, sometimes it is a bit tough.
And I'll just send
OSC messages saying,
hey keep up to this
time, you should be here.
How about over here.
Just kind of working
our way back.
The VR t-SNE experience
that you showed,
was that being
live coded as well?
Or is it something,
like could you--
Kind of.
So, I actually, I don't
know what I was thinking.
I'm bad at faking things.
I always want it to actually
be generative and interactive.
So, I built a system
in Unity whereby,
whenever I was live
coding, I was live
coding the system in Unity,
and I was procedurally
creating animation events so
that it captured my performance
and we would actually
[? replay ?] it.
And it would also send
the code that I had typed
and then type it in unity.
And, no one, people
who were just
like, that's a video, right.
Our friend, Adam.
Oh Yeah, Yeah.
But it was real.
Real.
Whatever that means.
Let's see.
Let's go over here.
Thanks a lot.
I'm really interested in new
kinds of live performance
and I'm wondering what you think
the vibe of algorave can do.
Or what's a new
kind of experience
that could come out of this
kind of live music performance?
Well, traditionally, like back
in 2012, the way people danced,
there was like an
algorave dance.
And it was just
a bunch of geeks.
You had beer in
one hand and you're
reading the code and
kind of going like this.
And so that's pretty boring.
But now, we've been
doing these shows
in New York and all kind
of lifting our chops
levels up and posting on
all sorts of weird lists.
And now would get all these
tech-savvy raver kids.
We don't know where they came
from or how they found us.
But they just dance.
They love this weird,
kind of, alien music,
and the vibe is really good.
And tomorrow I'm
missing our algorave
at [? Ibeam ?] in New York.
And, on April 20th, we're going
to play our biggest show ever
at this legendary, it's called
Performance Space, in New York,
and it's been kind
of a breeding ground
for experimental performance
and dance since the 80s.
And they just made
this new venue.
And they reached out to
us and they were like,
we want to try an algorave.
And we were like, do
you know what it is?
Are you sure?
But, they have
two 14k projectors
and seven 7K projectors.
So you are going to be
blinded by code at this show.
And it's in collaboration with
a group called Babycastles
that do indie video games.
So there's going to be
arcades everywhere, there's
going to be people wearing
arcades coming on the dance
floor and you could actually
play the arcade on them.
So, I feel like this feels like
a kind of futuristic that like,
hey, there's a lot of
geeks now and sometimes
they like to dance.
We like to dance, it's OK.
Who else?
There were some back there.
Let's go all the
way in the back.
I was wondering what your
relationship with the audience
is when you're performing
because on the one hand,
live performance is very like,
you're aware of your audience
that you're being watched.
But on the other
hand, when I'm coding,
I tend to just zone
out what's around me.
So I was wondering where you
sort of are on that spectrum.
Yeah, for me this is the
tragedy of live coding.
I come from a background of
being a very live and physical
performer and just being
keenly aware of the audience,
more than knowing they're
watching me just really feeling
the vibe.
And, yeah, you can't do
it when you're coding.
You can barely hear the music
when you're coding, really.
I mean, it's still
going in your ears,
but you're just so
razor focused on,
how do I get the next thing to
happen that, you're definitely
not embodied.
If anything, it's the opposite.
And, like I said, it doesn't
matter how you type the keys.
No one will feel it.
Sometimes I hit the
eval button extra hard.
That's the one action moment
in live coding is evaluate.
But Yeah, so, what my dream
was for this performance but,
I can't find anyone who
will leak one to me,
I want to get a Magic Leap
so that there's no laptop
and that I'm looking
at the audience, maybe,
and the code is floating
somewhere out there.
So that's my next step.
I tried it with the HoloLens
and I had such a headache
that I couldn't
code for two days.
So that was off the table.
It might still be a while before
you get what you really need.
But I think that, to me, seems
like it could be the solution.
That'd be one solution.
And the second is, I keep
getting to this point
where I'm live coding, like
sometimes I'll live code
and it'll be really algorithmic.
Like all sorts of loops and
iteration and nested 'if'
statements and these
really emergent properties.
And then as I find
what's cool in that,
I start abstracting it into
these little functions.
And I start just using
these little functions
like instruments and then I
say, hey, how many functions
am I really using, 10?
And so it makes me
wonder if there's
a way to build a system in
virtual reality, for instance.
Or mixed reality,
where you're coding,
but you're physically
moving around.
Like if there was a notion of
taking little chunks of code
and physically locating
them which might also just
help you spatially think
of the music in the space
and structurally
what's going on.
Yeah and then if it was,
again, Magic Leap, then I
feel like, it's like, I'm
here, the code is here
and I'm putting it around.
That would be cool.
Give me five years.
OK and then, there's
one question right
at the very back.
Hi so, I'll comment first,
your t-SNE in a t-SNE
reminded me of Escher,
so thanks for that.
So, I just started
engineering school
but I'm also a massage
therapist and a musician.
So something I
think about often,
is when I'm moving my clients
through body movements,
I'm usually thinking, I
wish I could hear or see
their stickiness.
And so, because of the Kinect
you were talking about,
I'm wondering, is
there anything you're
thinking about in health
care applications at all?
Yeah, I've always wanted
to build a Kinect app that
is like, hey, you're slouching.
You slouched for 95%
of today, or something.
And I never got around to it.
I don't know if Kinect
is the best way.
It's not very precise
to that level.
Like, I think these little
tightnesses are really precise.
But I did see a new
technology recently.
I forget what it's
called but, it
looks like one of those
Apple mouse things
and it sticks on
your back right here.
Oh, you guys know what it is.
And it measures the
angle of your spine
and it'll buzz you if
you slouch too much.
And so I want to get it.
I don't know if I'll
be able to stand it.
But I think there's a lot,
like I recently started
using the Muse headband.
I've been super skeptical
of EEG's but, this one
is pretty impressive for
the one little task it does.
And I sort of was
thinking about using,
the Muse is that EEG headset,
kind of consumer-grade, very
low spatial resolution.
But, supposedly will
tell you if you're, no,
I wouldn't say supposedly.
It definitely tells you
when your mind is active
and when you're
chill and focused.
And I've even tried
live coding with it.
So I thought,
maybe, if I had that
and that was an
input into the chain,
there could be a little bit
of the user's experience.
I don't know exactly how
that answers your question
but, I'm interested.
As a performer, I think the
current state of computers
is like, the less you use
them the healthier you are.
But, unfortunately,
in 2018 there
is nothing you can do that's
useful without a computer.
So, I feel like it's the
computer that has to change.
And you can all come up and
see my keyboard later on.
Very ergo keyboard.
Cool.
Let's see, back over there.
Yes, you.
So, I have two questions.
One is, is there
any situation where
you change what you
described as the system,
or the underlying
functions live?
And then my second question
is, how do you teach this
or how would someone
go about learning this?
Does it require extensive
experience improvising
in other music or
in music in general?
Wait, say the first question.
What was the first question?
The first question was, so
you talked about how you
changed the underlying system
I remember.
I try to avoid that live.
I do it all the time at home.
But it's definitely
risky because if you
make a mistake at
the low level, I
don't mean like
a doesn't compile
mistake, I mean it's not memory
managed, a low-level one.
So you could create a
memory leak in real time
while you're coding.
And I've also just done
something recursive
where I call a
function and I didn't
realize that, that function
calls a function that sometimes
calls that function, and
just blow up the stack.
But I would like to do that.
I think that's like
as cool as it can get,
to change that low-level stuff.
And I did use Unity
for the visuals
today because I'm always
toying with making this
into a VR experience.
But Extempore actually
has NanoVG and OpenGL,
and even [? an ?] open
source video game engine.
So you can do all
the visuals in it.
So, I think the most
interesting thing
is where you build
a system, then
use the high-level language
to put some patterns into it
and then you change the system
with those patterns in it.
And then the second thing was--
The second thing is, how
do you teach the stuff?
How do you teach your stuff.
Oh, it's great fun.
If you're learning
on your own, I
would not recommend Extempore.
I mostly wouldn't recommend
Extempore to anyone.
No, well I mean because, so--
Like I would never
join a club that
would accept me as a member.
No, no, it's more like, what's
his name, Fear and Loathing.
Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas.
Hunter S. Thompson.
At the beginning of
his book he says,
I would never recommend
drugs to anyone,
they just worked for me.
And, Yeah, so the creator of
Extempore, he specifically
said, there's this trend of
easy-to-use live coding tools
and this is just saying no.
This is going to give
you all the possibility
and all the power there is, and
it's really, really incredible.
I mean he controls robotic
telescopes with it.
So you're saying maybe
this is the second thing
you should learn.
Yeah, well, I mean look, if
you have a strong engineering
background, you'll
figure it out easy.
But if you're talking
about jump into it easily,
there's these other languages.
Especially Sonic Pi,
which is Ruby, and just
made with musicians in
mind, and it's very easy.
It doesn't matter if you have
a background in improvisation.
And then there's
other ones like Tidal,
which is this Haskell
language that's
all combining these
little operators to create
these emergent rhythms.
And that, you could just
mess with the numbers
and the order of the functions
and just see what you like.
So, there's languages
out there where
you could download it tonight
and start making cool beats.
But, Extempore is
more like a full,
it's not a [? library ?]
[? type ?] [? of ?] [? a ?]
language, it's its own language.
And then, the other
answer to that question
is, on Thursday night,
Jason is actually
teaching a class about this.
So folks who are
attending will, I think,
will leave the
class, essentially
having a basic feel
for how it works
and being able to make
their own live coded beats.
Yeah, and usually what
I find when I teach,
I teach the very basics
like, specify what note when,
kind of thing.
And, everyone takes it
in their own direction.
And half of the things
people do, I'm like,
I've never thought
of doing that.
Which actually, it kind of
reminds me of something,
I think you said, when we were
working on Harmonics, which
was, like one of the best
parts of this very rapid coding
is actually the accidents and
the mistakes and the bugs.
And when a bug turns
into a feature, or a bug
turns into sort of a new,
interesting artistic concept
that you wouldn't have
thought of otherwise.
And then you save it.
All my errors are
better than my ideas.
So I [? appreciate. ?]
And that actually kind of brings
me to sort of a higher level
question that I thought
maybe you could end with,
because we're pretty
close to out of time.
But you've taken us through
your whole life's journey, which
was amazing to see,
actually, how it all started
and how one thing
led to the other,
and this idea triggered
something that
happened to you years later.
And I love how there's an
overall overarching arc
of creativity and design.
And also there's a
lot of creativity
in the small with your
thinking about how
to be creative on a
second-to-second basis
with what we just saw here.
But my question really is, what
happens when you get stuck?
Like, does that happen to you?
Do you ever have writer's block,
or coder's block or something
like that?
And if so, how do
you get past it
and what is your
creative process
for coming up with new ideas?
No, my problem is the opposite.
Like I have too many
ideas, it just never ends.
And so, these days, I'm trying
to not be creative and just
work on execution because,
I'll start working on something
and then I'll think
of something else.
And I could just keep
coming up with new ideas.
OK but so, so all right,
so it's awesome you
don't have that problem.
Some of us might have that
problem every once in a while,
like what do I do next.
So, what would you say,
like what helps you?
How did you get to the
point where, essentially you
have too many ideas?
Oh, I don't know.
I think I was always like.
I don't know.
I mean I just can't, I mean
I get stuck in the subway
and I see a
[? Subway ?] commercial
and it gives me an
idea or something.
Write that down
everyone, subway--
No no no no no no.
Yeah, I'm really
hesitant to give advice
because I don't know why
I have all these ideas.
But, one thing I can
think of, I don't
know if it's the result,
the ideas, or the symptom
of the way my mind works.
But, I kind of never
had a very normal life,
like I'm constantly changing.
I freelance, I work
lots of contracts,
I'm always changing my
sleep cycle, traveling.
And your environment.
Environment, Yeah.
I'm not one to just stay.
Like I tried a full time
job about a year ago.
I did one year and I
just couldn't do it.
So, Yeah, I don't know.
I don't know if that's
helpful to other people.
Well just to my take on it from
looking at what you've done.
I think maybe one
way to interpret
it is that, you have done
a lot of different things
and had a lot of experiences.
But the way I think,
or I guess the way
I think Jason's mind works
is that, he essentially uses
every slight, little
opportunity that comes his way,
whether it's what he had
for breakfast or just
a blinking sign on the road.
Especially blinking signs.
Especially blinking
signs on the road.
But sometimes what you had
for breakfast as a way of,
everything is input
and everything
is sort of is going in.
And changing your
environment a lot
and trying all these
different things I
think all kind of contribute.
But what I see
happening is that, there
is this wonderful
feedback cycle happening
throughout your journey
where something happens here,
and then how to use it later.
And then that causes
something else to happen
and then you know
how to use it later.
And I think all those
things essentially
help feed on each other to,
essentially make this happen.
You know what, you just
made me think of something.
Something I did notice about
myself that I don't really
see other people doing, is
that I give a lot of attention
to unimportant details.
Unimportant details?
Attention to
unimportant details.
Yeah, like texture
on the floor or how
light reflects somewhere,
these kinds of things.
Or, the sound as
you're walking down
a hallway at a particular
spot sounds a certain way.
Yeah, that maybe that.
OK, so well that I
think, with that I think
we'll have to stop for tonight.
Thank you so much.
Thanks so much, Jason.
Thanks for coming.
It was great having you.